this episode is sponsored by magellan tv
a documentary streaming service founded
by filmmakers journey to the microcosmos
viewers will get a one month free trial
on magellan tv by clicking on the link
in the description
[Music]
do
[Music]
let's start today by agreeing on one
thing
this is weird
we're looking at a dark purplish screen
with little bits of white floating up
towards the top as if they are bubbles
rising to the top of a glass of grape
soda but that's not the weird part
the weird part happens when those
bubbles suddenly move in concert away
from the frothy edge dragged towards one
corner of the screen and then towards
the other the effect is cosmic like
we're watching a million stars get flung
towards each corner of the sky
and it won't make it any less weird to
know that we're not looking at bubbles
or stars we are looking at bacteria
a field of them shaped by an invisible
force that they are innately built to
respond to every swing towards one
direction and then another is visual
proof of this unseen thing so what is it
what is the force that's driving them to
move this way
technically it would not be wrong to say
that the answer is james our master of
microscopes
when james first saw these bacteria all
he knew was that they came from a sample
taken from a portuguese beach and on
each slide the bacteria were swimming in
a stark line and usually it's not that
strange to find bacteria swimming in a
line especially when you realize those
lines fall along particular chemical
gradients that correspond with the
bacteria's own needs but what was weird
to james is that the bacteria seemed to
be congregating entirely on one side of
the slide
at first he thought there might be some
kind of food source over there that was
drawing the bacteria towards that edge
so when he disposed of the slide he
moved on not expecting to see it happen
again
but the next day james took a drop of
water from his sample and added it to
the slide and there it was another line
just like he had seen the day before but
the line was sticking to one side of the
slide almost as if they were being
pulled by some invisible string in that
direction
and that gave james an idea
he took out his phone and opened up his
compass app and then he placed the phone
on the microscope stage to see what
direction the bacteria were swimming in
and he found that the bacteria were all
swimming north
so have we seen this line of bacteria
that's all swimming north what's with
the other things that we've been
watching where the bacteria look like
they are being dragged in other
directions
well as soon as james realized that his
bacteria were swimming north he decided
to go and grab some magnets to see if he
could trick them into thinking some
other direction is north instead so he
held the north end of the magnet close
to the slide the bacteria began to
migrate drawn in the direction of the
magnet and then he rotated the magnet so
that the south end pointed closer
driving the bacteria to swim away what
james had found what we are seeing in
action are magnetotactic bacteria or
bacteria whose movements are controlled
by earth's magnetic field
magnetotactic bacteria were first
described in 1963 by an italian
scientist named salvatore bellini who
found them living in fresh water and
when he saw them move with the same
singular northward focus that ours have
been exhibiting he considered the idea
that they might have some kind of
internal compass within them
but while bellini wrote up his work it
was only circulated as manuscripts to
some of the universities in italy
instead of being published in a journal
for more scientists to find
that meant that the existence of these
bacteria wasn't widely known when a
decade later a graduate student named
richard p blakemore collected some more
bacteria from a pond in massachusetts
and witnessed that northward microscopic
migration for himself blakemore coined
the term magnetotaxis to describe what
they were doing and as he dove deeper
into the bacteria to understand how they
moved this way he realized that they did
in fact have their own internal compass
or rather compasses
within these bacteria are a set of
organelles called magnetosomes the core
of the magnetosome is a magnetic crystal
either iron oxide or iron sulfide that's
made through a series of processes that
involve the cell taking in iron from its
surroundings and mineralizing it within
them the crystal is then wrapped in a
membrane to create a single magnetosome
but as we said magnetotactic bacteria
don't just have one magnetosome they
have a set of them usually around 10 to
20 arranged in a chain to create a
dipole that can respond to the magnetic
field that crosses the world around the
bacteria
magnetotactic bacteria are found all
around the world but their preference is
to live in areas with low levels of
oxygen like deeper down towards the
sediment and away from the surface
and this preference has potentially
important consequences for the direction
that magnetotactic bacteria travel in
all of the magnetotactic bacteria
discoveries we have described so far
including the bacteria we've been
watching travel north
however all those bacteria share
something else in common besides their
propensity towards the north pole they
all live
in the northern hemisphere meanwhile
scientists have found that magnetotactic
bacteria from the southern hemisphere
will actually travel towards the south
pole
this is probably due to the incline of
our planet's geomagnetic fields which
means that as a bacterium travels
towards its specified pole and its
preferred hemisphere it also swims
downwards in the water towards the
sediment it prefers
if a magnetotactic bacterium from the
southern hemisphere was forced to
navigate the magnetic field of the
northern hemisphere instead it would
find itself swimming upwards reaching
waters higher in oxygen and far less
comfortable for the bacterium
at least that is the hypothesis for why
this apparent polarity within the
distribution of bacteria exists
but as always there are exceptions
southern seeking bacteria found in the
northern hemisphere and other strange
behaviors that scientists are still
deciphering
there are many other mysteries to
magnetotactic bacteria like what
advantages magnetism even gives them
whether it's to find the right habitat
in the water or to hunt down particular
nutrients or a combination of different
factors and the bacteria probably don't
know why they move this way either it is
simply baked into them a crystal that
draws them into invisible tracks they
are mysterious and enigmatic you might
even call them magnetic
[Music]
thanks for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that
surrounds us
and thank you again to magellan tv for
sponsoring this episode of journey to
the micro cosmos there are a lot of
unseen worlds that surround us and while
we tend to focus on the ones we can fit
under the microscope the james webb
space telescope is out there studying
the atmospheres of exoplanets and
searching for the building blocks of
life elsewhere in the universe and you
can learn even more about that by
watching planet hunting with the james
webb space telescope on magellan tv
magellan tv is a documentary streaming
service founded by filmmakers it has
some of the most in-depth science
content available anywhere covering
space technology nature and more 15 to
20 hours of new content is added every
week with a growing collection of 4k
high definition content for no
additional cost so you will never run
out of something to watch and there are
no ads magellan tv can be watched
anytime anywhere on your television
laptop or mobile device because it's
compatible with roku amazon fire tv
apple tv google play and ios click on
the link in the description to get your
first full month of magellan tv for free
[Music]
all the people's names you see on the
screen right now they are people who
support us on patreon they give us a
little money so that we can continue
making this show because look we
understand that we are extremely excited
about magnetotaxis
but many people aren't and that's okay
it's a big diverse world but with tools
like patreon and great people like these
amazing content about amazing bacteria
can still survive on youtube so thank
you so much to all of them and if you
want to join them you can go to
patreon.com
journey2micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes james weiss you can check
out jam and germs on instagram and if
you want to see more from us there's
always a subscribe button somewhere
nearby
[Music]
you